chose dans mon métier ensuite gagner ma
vie ce qui est important
souffre arriver
son maillage et
si vous
encore
maison
fillon
amical
du soin et oued ziz white par exemple
comment venue d'écrire cette chanson je
veux dire je sais pas l'invasion vous
senti très
non mais c'est d'ailleurs ce n'est pas
une chanson que je m'identifie au
mouvement hippie pas du coup j'ai écrit
cette chanson en lisant un papier dans
la presse fava lui le papier dans le
journal et
avec tout un article sur le phénomène
ville devra être manipulé quelque chose
de social finalement c'était l'arrivée
de quelque chose de différent le
rassemblement de jeunes comme ça grâce à
la musique c'est quelque chose de
nouveau
j'ai senti que ça allait être très
important
et j'ai eu envie d'écrire une chanson là
dessus c'est tout
si le bois
10h chasse
chacun
ça va
non
je ne peux plus
hu
tu sois
m
je n'eus
soir
atta
c'est commun
wight is wight
eh oui
et puis
oui
ouah
que tu sois
tes amis
oui
puis
là
pour aller plus loin
et vous
je suis
lui
comme attendu
qu'est ce que ça vous gêne par exemple
si on donne une autre étiquette monsieur
tube
oui monsieur tubes seul jet parce que je
trouve ça tout ça consulting au sein
nous genre monsieur machin sa mère que
monsieur tour de france widor monsieur
deuxième les étiquettes comme ça c'est
si c'est toujours un petit peu ridicule
et puis en plus de ça j'ai pas la façon
d'être vraiment monsieur tu sais j'ai
fait plein de disques qui n'ont pas fait
d'études
oui mais j'ai jamais recherché le
tubiste rohff qui en a eu comme ça parce
que mais je me fonds était je pense été
les chansons populaires qui était
accessible à tout le monde et puis donc
les gens ils ont connu la plupart du
temps dans certaines de mes chansons
ils les ont achetés les en ont fait des
tubes se tait quand l'amplitude pas
moins seul mot idole j'ai une gêne pour
moi parce que le sommet ne convient pas
du tout
pourquoi parce qu'une idole c'est
quelqu'un qui est qui est toujours fort
c'est d'être en représentation 20 compte
ni dole c'est quelqu'un qu'on vénère
donc qui se doit d'être toujours au
service du public service du public lors
vous suivant la parlant de trois jours
j'avais l'impression à l'anc nous étions
au service du public je suis au service
public quand je chante sur une scène
quand je suis en contact direct avec le
public
parce que là c'est mon rôle je dois être
au service du public c'est mon métier
je suis très bien voilà
comme ça c'est très simple il ne nous
reste plus qu'à fin
na je dis ah parce que votre public
contredirait bien sûr c'est un petit peu
le public des amoureux de peynet c'est
le seul prix mais c'est sûrement un
public de rêveur je pense qu'on a le
public le public qu'on a cessé sont les
gens qui nous ressemble un petit peu en
fin de compte et vous êtes un peu un
personnage je sais pas si j'ai un
perçage penney ce que je peux dire c'est
que c'est que je suis suis rêveur donc
je pense que les gens qui viennent me
voir qu'ils achètent mais disent que ce
sont aussi des rêveurs vision qui ont
besoin de s'évader comme moi j'en ai
besoin
elle est encore plus profondément son
père et sa mère
qui parle de moi